thank you so much for having me beam in
live from chicago today
and as manish was saying today i'm going
to tell you about this lofty goal that i
have of imagining all of people on a
trustworthy internet
um
so i work in the department of computer
science here at the university of
chicago and i run the air lab
my lab essentially
so in my lab um basically we really love
the internet i love the internet because
i can actually beam in from chicago to
see you right now i love that i can use
it for communication i love that i can
use it for work or even entertainment
and so in my lab we've been really
looking at how to help people manage
different aspects of internet usage
whether that's around privacy and
security helping people to recognize
misleading online content or even to
answer questions like why is my internet
really slow or why have i run out of
data right so we cover performance and
cost as well now today i don't have time
to tell you about all of these other
things my lab does and so i just wanted
to give you a quick idea of what we do
and then go into the main body of the
tool so we're very much a mixed methods
lab we run user studies we do web
scraping internet measurements we also
create tools that are user-facing and we
have a big focus on trying to impact
consumer protection policy
like many of you there in stanford
taking this hdi seminar i follow
user-centered design so a lot of my work
looks at trying to figure out what user
needs are we do designing prototypes
implementing and evaluating these
prototypes and theory also plays a large
part in what we do
so in privacy and security you know i've
looked at everything from user mental
models of drones to online tracking um
try to help people with education and
awareness around privacy and security
including for in-person novice
protesters for example
um again today i'll be speaking a little
bit about how trying to help people
recognize misleading online content like
misinformation
uh well not today i will be speaking
about that but that's one of the things
we do and then like i said we've built a
number of tools to help people with
managing internet speeds and and data
costs
so although my lab does all of these
different things um today i wanted to
focus on the reflections that i've had
after almost a decade of work in these
different spaces
to try to think about how we can make
the internet more inclusive and
trustworthy now why do i want the
internet to be more inclusive
um well you know my lab is really
focused on understanding what kinds of
needs we would need to meet to have a
trustworthy internet and i noticed that
not as many people do work in
marginalized or unmarginalized and
underserved communities or looking
through the lifespan of the human from
when you know someone is very young to
someone becoming an older adult
i also in my lab really want to focus on
making the internet more trustworthy by
identifying misleading online content
online as well as creating tools to help
users evaluate misleading online content
so why do i care about all the people on
the internet well here's a very simple
schematic i created since hci started in
the 80s uh basically all of the research
tends to be on very homogenous
populations far fewer of the hci
research studies that we we see are
actually on non-westernized or
industrialized nations on marginalized
and underserved communities and there's
also far fewer studies or research
across the lifespan of people
um so to better inform designs of tools
um for privacy and security and i trust
with the internet i feel it's really
important that we start to look more
broadly and get more research in this
little light orange part of this uh
schematic
so why am i worried about trustworthy
content well i'm sure many of you over
there just like over here in chicago
especially during the pandemic have
encountered content online that's
labeled as misleading right
but there are other types of misleading
online content perhaps you've done
online shopping and maybe you've been
seeing interfaces where you're asked to
sign up for a mailing list and often
you're presented with asymmetric visual
choices where the thing that the
provider wants you to sign up with is
very prominent and then you also have
some sort of guilty confirm shaming kind
of language which says you know do you
want to sign up and save so i sign up
and get the coupon or do i click instead
nah i like paying full price
similarly on other aspects of the
internet like social media
there are people who are influencers who
have lots and lots of followers like
here dj khaled and his instagram post
and he is not disclosing that he's
actually having a sponsored post here
and he was taken to task for this
because he has a really young following
and this was found to be you know like
potentially having a negative effect on
them so we really need to inform
internet policies and we need to help
users critically evaluate content to
protect from online math pieces
so today i'm going to tell you about
four different projects in my lab or
four sets of projects in my lab that
kind of touch on uh you know us our sort
of work to reach these goals so first
let's think about imagining all the
people
and let's in particular look at how
privacy and security is managed by
low-income mobile users in south africa
so the takeaway i want you to get here
is basically i want you to question
assumptions about what our average users
look like
so let's take a step back so this is a
set of studies we did in south africa if
you know a lot about the country of
africa i mean the continent of africa
although it's not a country there are
actually 54 countries on the continent
um south africa is just one of them at
the very bottom
and
the internet is really mobile there when
users get online they tend to do so for
the first time on a mobile device just
to give you an example um a few years
ago i pulled a stat that shows that most
of the mobile connect and most the
internet connectivity is through mobile
subscriptions and not fixed for band
subscriptions
also data is really expensive there so
this is from a internet service provider
called mtn and you'll see that they say
oh you know different various pricing
for different amounts of data you can
get 40 megabytes of data for about 10
rand that equates to about 60 u.s cents
but
when we interviewed low-income mobile
users there in the study that i'm going
to tell you about
they were earning on average less than
four dollars a day so 60 cents which may
not seem a lot um you know just thinking
about that number actually becomes a
huge amount of someone's income when
they're very very low income
so why look at privacy on social media
in south africa you know social media
usage is on the rise globally but like i
was saying before most studies on
privacy in
social media and how we manage that
tends to be on resource
rich nations and there are far fewer
studies that are conducted in these
resource-poor settings
and most of them focus on facebook but
not necessarily in countries like south
africa
so we try to sort of fill this gap and
set about trying to understand how users
actually manage privacy on social media
in this low-income setting this just
shows you some of the pictures of the
interview settings where we actually
conducted some of our interviews just to
give you um you know a view as to how
this differs from say where you're
sitting
in your lecture theater there in
stanford
so i just want to tell you a little bit
about our methods when we actually say
we interviewed someone generally we
would come in get their consent ask them
questions about social media usage ask
about themes that may touch on privacy
and security without bringing those up
explicitly and then audio tape the
interviews compensate people and then
transcribe them before we go into data
analysis
and i just want to tell you also about
what were the kinds of people that
participated in this study so we had an
even gender split of male and female
identifying participants again they were
very low to low income and they tended
to skew towards a younger age range
and i just want to tell you a couple of
highlights of things that i found really
interesting from this work the first was
unlike many people who are managing
privacy on social media here and say the
us
i found that most of the participants we
spoke to didn't really consider privacy
from the service provider so someone
like facebook as an issue
typically when they were mentioning
privacy issues it was to do with other
people and this often a lot of the
privacy issues stem from the fact that
not many people are just using one
person per device but there's a lot of
device sharing
among this low-income group in south
africa and so for example one
participant was talking about privacy
issues of how
their girlfriend changed their password
access their facebook and read their
messages and so this came up again and
again because device sharing is so much
more prominent there
another thing is um facebook as some of
you may know i know it's been in the
news a lot for many different things but
facebook actually has quite a fine level
of granularity in terms of its privacy
settings you can tweak and do quite a
few things with it but when we spoke to
the users in south africa over half of
them didn't even know that you could
actually tweak these settings they just
assumed that on facebook in particular
um content had to be public by default
and so there was a much more heavy
reliance on the concept of blocking
someone in this all-or-none approach
also data costs actually limited
people's ability to use privacy settings
many of them even if they did know
privacy settings that it was too
expensive to sort of be clicking through
all these different settings and one
example
one of our participants actually had her
account hacked and she abandoned the
recovery process because she had to
spend so much data to get an email
recovery asking her to reset her
password and and all these different
steps so eventually she just said hey
i'm just i'm that constant is gone i'm
going to create a new facebook account
also unfortunately south africa is a
country with a high crime rate and so we
really found that physical security
affected people's privacy behaviors and
how they actually interacted on social
media
so many of the people that we spoke to
told us about how often their phones or
other devices were being stolen and so
they thought of social media as a data
storage even though many of them felt
that the posts had to be public we found
that a lot of them were telling us that
they were uploading photos to facebook
so that if their phones got stolen they
would still have access to that data
also because of this concern for
physical safety people were mentioning
things like seeing posts online getting
lured um you know and by promises of job
opportunities getting loaded to meet
someone and then having something really
bad like being robbed or worse happened
to them so there were very very uh
cautious about posting in real time
which is unlike you know what we're used
to here in the states people there
thought very much more about whether
they were posting something and who
might see personal details like if you
were posting a picture of kids people
told us they didn't want people to see
the school uniform and know where their
kids actually went to school so it was
very different to what we're used to
thinking about when we think about
average users in the states
so the major takeaway here is that
really we have to question our
assumptions about the average user's
privacy needs
not everyone knows about privacy
settings so even if they're really well
designed or offer lots of different
controls that may not be making a
difference to many different people who
are on social media
also not everyone can afford to spend a
lot of time setting up privacy settings
and people may have other concerns that
affect their privacy and security for
example having to upload your data
publicly just because of physical
security threats
so if we're trying to you know reach
this goal of imagining all the people on
the internet we really have to think
about what that means and get more
research on different types of
populations and their privacy and
security needs
so now that we thought about different
kinds of populations let's think about
imagining all the people in terms of the
human lifespan what happens when we
really think about the youngest of
internet users kids and so here i'm
going to tell you about a project that
we had for the last five years on
helping kids to learn about online
privacy and security and the takeaway i
want you to get here is that we have to
educate the youngest of our internet
users
so let's take a look at why internet
users are getting younger and why they
might need some help
play ticker digger
let's
[Music]
alexa
okay so that's just an example of as
technology is becoming more ubiquitous
designers don't always understand that
different types of users like kids may
be interacting with them and things can
go wrong
quite quickly okay so
oops so a couple of that you know kids
especially recently you know with the
pandemics starting have had to
experience a new norm just like i'm
speaking to you in this sort of hybrid
format kids have had to deal with things
like uninvited visitors zoom bombing
their calls
having to figure out how to do text
chatting or etiquette around naming
backgrounds turn taking or even having
to think about what happens to
recordings of videos that are taken
about taken of them in the classroom
also there are many different security
issues that have come about because of
technology use in schools for example
here in chicago late last year the
chicago public schools district found
that there was a bug in one of the
software systems called go guardian
where teachers could actually initiate a
call to a webcam and have it
automatically answered without the
student's consent essentially giving
them a view right into the student's
webcam wherever it was in the home
luckily they were able to detect this
bug and they quickly shut it down
but because of these privacy and
security issues
my collaborators and i started thinking
about how do kids actually think about
privacy and security and what kinds of
resources would they need to help learn
how to manage online privacy and
security and there are many different
stakeholders in this process a child is
not an island a child has a parent their
teachers and other stakeholders is
involved so what we've been doing is
we've been conducting interviews and
focus groups with educators
so again here after the interviews we
usually go through a process of
qualitative data analysis so we might
actually sit down and say let's create a
code book that encompasses all the
different themes that we're looking for
in a particular set of interview
transcripts for example we might have a
code that looks for what kinds of
activities do children do on devices and
we might have sub codes like maybe they
play games
we usually then take the transcripts and
then we apply the codes or labels to
those transcripts
and then once we have done that with all
the transcripts and had numerous uh
research meetings to discuss these
transcripts we group these codes into
categories and we usually come up with
the final themes that we then report in
research presentations like this and in
research papers
now i don't have time to go through all
the themes that have come out of this
work but again i want to give you some
highlights
the first thing we learned regards
parents so parents often think of young
kids because this research is focused on
elementary school-aged kids between the
ages of five to eleven
they often think that young kids even if
they're online for remote school and so
on that they're not on social media
they're not really having to think about
privacy and security until a later age
similarly um not only are parents
thinking let's defer this to a later
time this kind of learning they're often
unsure of online privacy and security
issues themselves so they don't feel
well qualified to teach kids about these
issues
and so they are very dependent on this
home school partnership
and now when we turn to teachers in the
classroom
both during the pandemic as well as
pre-pandemic when we were speaking to
teachers they told us about the tech use
in the classroom and thinking about
technology is either just the means
towards the learning outcomes or
as means to actually keep students to
task so again systems like lan school
and goguardian which have displayed here
each one of these little rectangles here
and each one of these little rows are
basically a student's laptop and so
students
teachers basically have this window into
what students are doing because they're
trying to monitor them and keep them
you know on task for whatever the lesson
plan is they're also especially in
remote times trying to see if a
student's engaging are they logging on
are they doing things like that and so
they're really considering online
privacy and security it's not a top
priority
when privacy and security does come up
in the classroom it's typically around
passwords and for young kids who have
little finger
and don't have very good typing skills
as well as you know are at the
developmental age where maybe they're
still learning how to spell
and still learning how to read it
becomes very complicated with passwords
and so teachers are often getting kids
to use passwords with personally
identifiable information and writing
them down on cards which they then send
home
so
as you know years later we're often
saying to people like us do not do this
do not ever write down your password on
a piece of paper and so kids are
essentially learning poor online
security hygiene
and privacy hygiene and then later on
they have to sort of unlearn these
habits
so teachers don't really have time to
incorporate this existing uh kind of
learning into curricula and they have to
deal with these developmental issues and
also manage things like passwords and so
on
so we took that learning and then we
moved to the next step in the design
process and said okay how do we actually
start creating educational resources for
kids
so some of you may know the game doodle
jump if you don't it's this really
addictive platform game for your mobile
phone with this cute little character
sort of jumps up different platforms and
you can earn points
so we imagined with child design
partners this game called privacy doodle
jump and we said you know given that
privacy and security is so contextual
what if we could have this quiz that
would expose kids to different scenarios
where they'd have to manage privacy for
example perhaps some websites asking
them to input private data and maybe we
could give them encouraging messages if
they sort of make better choices and if
they make poorer choices we could kind
of set them in the right direction
so we evaluated this with the child
partners and to sum up our efforts one
of our child partners said i hate it
when they take a perfectly good game and
they try to make it educational right so
there's a very fine line between making
something that's fun and engaging for
kids and something that actually helps
them learn about privacy and security
so despite this sort of disheartening
comment uh we actually continued in this
process we took the feedback from our
child design partners and we actually
went ahead and made this mobile game
called cybernaut which we also evaluated
with kids
and with the feedback from this as well
as other resources like choose your own
adventure stories we're starting to
learn what kinds of things kids find
useful and helpful and engaging
and actually want to use to learn about
privacy and security
so some of the things we've learned are
that do's and don'ts are not effective
for kids they really need to know why
they shouldn't do something like why
shouldn't i input that private
information when someone's asking from
it why shouldn't i tell someone my
password if it's a stranger
also kids really need relatable
everyday scenarios so for example if i
was to have some sort of scenarios and
and do the same project in stanford you
know i might use things like you know
stories about the giants or things like
that as opposed to the chicago cubs
right because even those kinds of
relatable everyday scenarios and touches
on stories and context that kids are
presented with really help them to
relate to those concepts and it sort of
helps the learning take place
and then finally kids really need this
toolbox of strategies to help cope with
the fact that privacy and security is
very contextual and so you know rather
than just giving them a list of do's and
don'ts we need to give them lots of
different kinds of things that they can
do for example if they see something
they don't understand maybe one strategy
is to ask a trusted grown-up about what
they should actually
do so the major takeaway here from this
body of work so far is that we really
have to educate the youngest of our
internet users if we want to reach this
goal but trustworthy internet for all
and this doesn't just involve kids but
all their parents teachers as well as
their caregivers and more generally
privacy and security needs are not just
limited to sort of adult users but they
span across the human lifespan and so
our lab is also starting to look at
privacy and security needs for older
adults as well
finally you know kids are getting used
to more kind of surveillance through
bulgaria and land school and other kinds
of technologies so they're actually
having changing notions of what privacy
and security means
already we've tried to uh you know work
with the federal trade commission
through commenting and so on to help
them understand how these kinds of
things we're learning might uh influence
policies like the children's online
privacy protection act which actually
regulates what data can be collected on
kids
so now that i've told you a bit more
about imagining all the people on a
trustworthy internet let's focus in on
how do we make a trustworthy internet so
now i want to give you um
an idea of a project that we've been
doing on dark patterns and shopping
websites so here the takeaway is if we
want to create a trustworthy internet we
first need to see what kinds of content
is not trustworthy on the internet
so say i actually did want to come to
stanford today maybe i say hey i had
such an amazing time at this seminar
today i want to take a flight this
afternoon what if i tried to book my
flight i might see a message like hmm
there's only one ticket left at this
price and if you're like me often when
i'm booking flights i think is there
really only one ticket left or is that
just some sort of trip to get me to buy
the flight
well as it turns out some websites are
trying to trick you and they're using
dark patterns to make you do things like
that you may not have otherwise done
like book a trek a trip to stanford this
afternoon or even signing up for
something
and more broadly dark patterns are user
interface design choices that coerce
steer or deceive you into making a
decision that if you were fully informed
and presented with all the alternatives
you may not have otherwise made
so there are many different taxonomies
of different kinds of dark patterns and
i won't go into detail of all the
different types of dark patterns that
people have named but this is really
based on anecdotal evidence one of the
dark patterns i actually showed you
earlier is called confirm shaming and
that's where again people have
asymmetric choices in the interface so
again you can see the sign up and get
coupon
box is much more clear and easy to click
on whereas the the na i like playing
full price is sort of less visible and
then also there's that language which is
trying to shame you into doing what the
provider wants
now because there was just anecdotal
evidence we wanted to actually set about
to see are dark patterns actually
prevalent on the internet and so we
decided to look at dark patterns and
shopping because users have to make a
decision to purchase something
so we set about and we gathered a corpus
of 11 000 of the most popular shopping
websites online
and we had some challenges we had to
deal with for example we had to mimic a
real user browsing the shopping website
we had to then collect and store the
data from all these shopping websites
and then we had to actually analyze that
data to see if there were dark patterns
present
so just to give you an idea of how we
addressed some of those challenges
for the first challenge we created a
shopping bot so our shopping bot would
actually visit each of the product pages
or some subset of project pages on each
of those websites and would sort of
mimic a user shopping in this case if i
was on macy's for shoes our bot would
actually try to choose different options
for the colors the sizes and so on and
once it worked its way through many of
the different options it would actually
add it to the cart and then go to the
shopping cart web page since we didn't
have a lot of cash obviously we didn't
purchase these products and so our
analysis stopped here but at each of
these points we took screenshots and
took
screenshots of both pop-ups and all the
visuals on each of the websites
as well as did some other analysis
so as a lower bound because our shopping
bot and crawler did not look at every
single page on every single shopping
website we looked at we are just saying
that the patterns we found are kind of a
lower bound and we found that in those
11 000 shopping websites at least 11 of
them had some sort of dark patterns
present
so i'm going to give you an example of
some of these dark patterns
the first is a dark pattern called
urgency this is trying to create the
sense that you really have to buy
something now or you're going to miss
out and usually websites have been
using this tactic of
putting timers on their shopping
websites so if you've done online
shopping you may have seen this often a
time it says you know it says something
like an offer is about to expire or
sales about to end or if you really want
to get a discount that you have to do it
within a specified amount of time
so not only did we see that this was
prevalent across our data set but we
also noticed that in cases where we were
revisiting the timers to see what
happened when the timer expired there
was basic deception so some of the
timers just reset when they expired and
in other cases the offer was still valid
even when the timer expired
i already talked about the dark pattern
of misdirection which is trying to get
you to do one thing
um and this dot pattern of confirm
sharing was actually quite prominent and
prevalent across the websites so here
again in the user interface design you
the user is presented with visually
asymmetric choices as well as language
that tries to guilt them into doing the
thing the provider wants so in this case
there's two examples here of you know
would you like this 15 discount you'd
say yes i'd like that discount no thanks
i like paying full price or and there's
more uh you know a little bit uh more
egregious example no thanks i'd rather
pay the pay full price for things club
so the final dark pattern example i'll
tell you about is a dark pattern called
social proof this is where the providers
are trying to show you that other people
are doing this as well and you should
get on the bandwagon and so usually this
typically you know one way this
manifests in giving you activity
notifications so it might say something
like jacqueline from jacksonville just
save 52 in her order or in other cases
it may say something like 28 people have
viewed this in the last 24 hours
or 28 people have this in their shopping
cart
so not only did we see that this was
prevalent but we also found some
deceptive examples as well
in the most egregious example here
there's a site called thredup.com where
we found that basically these
notifications were just drawn from two
sets of strings and so they quite easily
could have said sarah from san francisco
just saved 52
on her order
not only did we see lots of different
dark patterns on websites but we also
found there's a whole ecosystem that
provides these kinds of dark patterns to
shopping websites so they're platforms
where you can easily set up our online
shopping website called shopify and
there are many third-party plug-ins that
allow you to do
urgency pressured selling and these
kinds of dark patterns as well
if you'd like to find out more about the
other kinds of dog patterns that we
found
you're welcome to visit this repository
we have at princeton which is the
institution i was at previously
so the major takeaway i want you to get
from that study or that set of studies
is that if you identify misleading
online content you really can inform
policy and tools
um this large-scale evidence is really
useful for informing regulations and
tool design in fact we've worked with
the federal trade commission to have
discussions about what does it mean for
a dark pattern to be dark what is the
line between
something that is bad or something
that's plain marketing for example
and i'm happy to report that in
california
they've already banned some kinds of
dark patterns particularly ones that
relate to privacy
so
the final sets of studies that i want to
talk about are basically if we want to
create a trustworthy internet it may not
be enough to have data sets of what
could be considered misleading online
content how do we actually take that
content or take what we've learned and
create user-facing tools
so in the takeaway here i want you to
understand that yes we can create
user-facing tools to help people
recognize misleading online content and
i'm going to give you an example of how
we did that
so i'm going to be talking about a
project where we try to help people
recognize disguise advertisements on
social media
but first and i'll give a trigger
warning here this camera angle here is a
little bit shaky but this is an
influencer so let's take a look at an
influencer on youtube
when i was a kid all i ever wanted to be
was a youtuber all i ever did was make
videos hey who's this oh it's me funny
enough i was actually voted most likely
to be a youtuber in high school and
after i graduated i made a promise to
myself that i was gonna do it
okay so that is an influencer someone
who has a lot of different followers on
social media in this case her name is
elle of the mills this is a video that i
pulled a while ago from her website
or her channel on youtube she had 1.6
million subscribers the video alone had
1.9 million views
and in this video elle is talking about
how she was having a nervous breakdown
and how using a service called
betterhelp.com which is kind of like a
counseling service that hooks you up
with different therapists really helps
her to work through these issues what l
does not tell you in the video
description that's the text below the
video is that every time someone signs
up for betterhelp.com using her link or
even clicks on that link she actually
earns a bit of money and this is called
affiliate marketing and importantly elle
does not disclose that she's earning
money from giving you this information
about this service
however the federal trade commission
which oversees the consumer protections
on the internet says if there's a
connection between someone like l and a
marketer like betterhelp.com that you
need to disclose that relationship
otherwise it's considered deceptive
advertising and so companies can
actually be taken to task for this
if they're not disclosing and similarly
influencers have to disclose
when they have these kinds of
connections
so we wanted to first find out again
is this a problem do people do affiliate
marketing and how many of them are
actually disclosing so we again gathered
a data set of half a million view videos
on youtube as well as two million two
million pens
and we looked and at all the video
descriptions and all the pin
descriptions and try to find all the
urls in those descriptions
out of the url dataset we started to
notice a pattern for affiliate marketing
link urls we noticed that when there's
an affiliate marketing link url the
marketer like betterhelp.com needs to
know or have an identifier for the
influencer in this case l and so
typically in the url itself they have
some sort of identifier for the
influencer that is doing the referrals
and this pattern holds for all different
kinds of affiliate marketing links
sometimes it's you know as simple as the
l parameter that i showed you but
sometimes it's actually in the url
parameters itself
and we can use this key
observation to actually map out what are
the different types of affiliate
marketing link companies affiliate
marketing companies as well as what are
the different patterns these companies
use
so one of the biggest affiliate
marketing companies is one that you
probably know well it's amazon.com
so next now that we know you know we can
actually detect affiliate marketing
links we started to look at the
description so again recall this is
something that you usually have to click
through that's below a video on youtube
and we looked at the pinterest
descriptions to see
you know we wanted to first find out how
common is it that if someone is doing
affiliate marketing like el of the mills
that they actually disclose that they're
doing this
and if you know unsurprisingly or maybe
surprisingly that only ten percent of
these affiliate marketing videos and
seven percent of the affiliate marketing
pins on pinterest actually had any sort
of disclosure that the influencers were
doing affiliate marketing
and we examine these and categorize them
into three broad types of disclosures
the first is something that we termed an
affiliate link disclosure where an
influencer might say something like
affiliate links may be present
now the federal trade commission
actually explicitly discourages this
because you know if you were like me
before this project i didn't even know
what affiliate marketing was
and so
they you know don't want people to have
just such a basic disclosure
the second kind of disclosure we noticed
was what we called an explanation
disclosure where a person tries a little
harder to say that they're earning money
so they might say something like this is
an affiliate link and i receive a
commission for the sales
the final type is just something where
we noticed on youtube that people often
say click on this link and you'll
support my youtube channel
now not only uh is it not that common to
actually disclose when you're doing
affiliate marketing
at least from our data set it's also the
fact that the most common kinds of
disclosures that we found were the very
basic affiliate link disclosures that
the federal trade commission
discourages so now that we know that
this is actually something that isn't
being disclosed we actually move to try
to create a tool
before and to inform the design of the
tool we first wanted to know do users
actually understand these different
types of disclosures so we ran an
experiment on mechanical turk where we
exposed users to different types of
disclosures and we saw which ones they
understood the most
as it turns out users understand
explanation disclosures the most and
affiliate link disclosures are as we
suspected not as easy to understand
we then took this information and we
actually incorporated
it into a tool
so our tool is called ad intuition it's
a browser extension that we developed
for chrome and firefox and ad intuition
works by loading the youtube video
checking the links in the video
description and seeing if they're
affiliate marketing links or promotion
codes and then if so putting up a
minimally intrusive banner that lets you
know when something's sponsored
and in addition to that it also
highlights the links and promotion codes
in the video descriptions
we ran a study um with over 300 users in
the wild to see if the tool worked and
it did do classification and detection
very well in the wild we also conducted
a diary study and found that it was very
helpful for users to have this tool
because in many cases they were watching
influencers who they did not know were
doing affiliate marketing or in some
cases that they suspected we're doing
affiliate marketing and had confirmation
of that
so this tool really did help people to
understand and become a little bit more
aware of the fact that
influences can be engaged in this
practice
and that tool although it's a browser
extension could arguably be built into
the browser itself
so the major takeaway here is that user
facing tools can help users to identify
misleading online content and these
kinds of tools are useful for creating a
more trustworthy internet it also
informs internet policy for example
through the tool as opposed to our
random randomly collected data set of
youtube videos we were actually able to
see how users watch videos in the wild
one thing i found surprising or maybe
not surprising in retrospect is that a
lot of users tend to watch the same
influences over and over again
and so that means that they either are
you know there might be some users that
are disproportionately exposed to
affiliate marketing
as a random aside uh fun tidbit
pewdiepie who was at the time of this
research one of the biggest influences
on youtube um when i pulled this video
he had 83 million subscribers and this
video alone had four million views uh
when our work got some press he actually
started using the basic affiliate link
type disclosures
so again
much like my other work we've tried to
distill our findings and help you know
give presentations to the federal trade
commission and help them with commenting
on the online endorsement guidelines to
help influence the policies around this
so i want to close by saying you know
imagining all the people in our trust
with the internet you know i hope today
i've also helped you think and question
your assumptions about what the average
internet user's needs are
i hope i've convinced you that we need
to educate the youngest of internet
users about privacy and security and we
do need to identify what other types of
misleading online content exists online
as well as work to create tools to help
people to critically evaluate this
content
and so just as a reminder my lab is
working on all of these different things
and
i'd love to take questions now thank you
so much
we have time for questions so
okay great um
um
how do you kind of find a balance
between
regulating internet use and making it um
private enough and safe enough for
people to use without
encroaching too much on freedom of
speech and behavior online
oh
that's probably uh i think i probably
need a few dissertations worth of
time to answer that question fully
um but you know i think it is a fine
line
even when it comes to identifying
misleading online content it's not
straightforward for example even with
something like labeling a video as a
sponsored video became tricky if we
weren't sure if our detection was
working accurately or like when we were
looking at promotion codes we tried to
use different colors and different
messaging to say when we weren't certain
about something so almost like saying
this might be sponsored but it may not
be so i feel like yes you could have
cases where
the way you're regulating or the way
you're flagging something can actually
affect or be used or misused to censor
someone
but i still think that there's some
basic privacy protections that we can
put in in terms of regulation to
incentivize providers to do the right
thing when it comes to privacy right so
i don't think there's a there's a answer
i can give you quickly now in this talk
but i think it's a very good question
i have a question about your slide
lessons learned uh relating to kids and
privacy yes
the the various bullet points i i
resonated with them personally a lot
and so
to me like it could have been lessons
learned you know relating to adults
are there are the differences that you
found
um beyond those bullet points or is this
something that they also
feel why the difference really
differences in how we should address
kids and adults because i find often
times
we as we expect there to be a difference
only to find that there's not that much
difference
yes i'm glad you said that um and i'd
say no actually many of the things that
we're doing for kids could work just as
easily for adults um or even older
adults um so
i think that
you know many adults struggle with
privacy and security issues and don't
know how to manage these things i think
the main difference when we're coming to
situ uh like designing for kids is that
we try to because of the developmental
age because of the physical differences
and so on we do have to design things
that are more specific to that age range
um even though we may be trying to
address the same issues so for example
one project we had was um
you know which i don't have any write-up
on was we tried to make something that
would help kids understand online
tracking and so we built a tracker a
blocker sorry
a browser extension that would turn all
the trackers on a web page into little
aliens and visualize them so that kids
could see that things were watching them
right so that could be fun for an adult
but i feel like certain things might be
more engaging for a child just because
of the age that they're in and so mostly
when we're thinking about it although
the issues may be similar you know the
kind of designs that we create are very
much focused on children
and if we were thinking about older
adults or adults we would maybe have the
same kind of learning behind it but we
might change the designs to suit the
different age groups
thank you
other questions
do we get questions online yeah they
have to just put the raisin in their
hand feature and then i can unmute them
but right now we don't have any okay
questions great question over here yeah
i was wondering when you had this slide
discussing how i think it was the ftc or
one of the government bodies had to
mandate kind of like the sponsored
um
notification for users i was wondering
from like a policy standpoint and as a
technologist working hand-in-hand with
people in government like how long did
it take to
um
get that put in place
right so i were sort of cutting out a
little bit i think you were asking about
how
how do you get that sort of influence
with your work with the federal trade
commission did i get that right
um i think you know i was just fortunate
that um i was
i happened to sort of meet and connect
with some folks that
were in the federal trade commission so
i think that that helped a lot um
basically in my work so far both when i
was living in dc
as well as since i've been away from
there
is that often times it's very much like
personal relations sorry that's my timer
to make sure it didn't go over time um
it's very much personal relationships
that help you to kind of uh get your
work seen and heard about by the right
people and once you have those personal
relationships then it becomes much
easier to say hey i have this kind of
study which i think you know really
relates to this regulatory issue that
you're working on or vice versa where
they could say
we have this issue that we need evidence
on
you know is there any research in this
or
are you working on this and so on so i
feel like just like with many other
things in academia that a lot of this
stuff seems to be you know
personal relationships and it did help i
think initially for me to be located in
dc where i was closer and was able to
meet more people uh but a lot of the
stuff is just like through networking
hello
thank you for the great talk i was
curious about related to the first part
of your presentation on
how people interact with the internet in
especially low-income
neighborhoods or countries um so in the
us we have the ftc to as a governing
body for uh some types of media
interaction how have you found kind of
government or governing of the internet
to be in
um developing nations compared to the
ftc
right different interaction
uh yeah so i mean i so in south africa
um
there is like there are similar sort of
governing bodies but i'd say
um in some cases they're ahead of
certain things like in terms of privacy
and in other cases they're behind just
because the infrastructure isn't as well
developed um so i feel like it's it's
it's not always the case that like
you know one country is like very well
developed than another and i think it
just depends on the context for example
i know south africa says that it's not
legal to spread misinformation um but
that's because they've had a lot of
issues around misinformation being
spread around elections right so
um and i'm not sure we have the same
thing here so i feel like working there
um it's much it's very similar like at
the end of the day we're all people so
again it's about like you know i was
again
fortunate to work with a non-profit
there when i was living in south africa
and doing like an internship there and
so um or a postdoc there and um
i feel like you know again a lot of this
stuff is just about
trying to get your message to the right
people so that you can affect change
um hopefully that answers your question
yeah thank you very much
um and i see a question
um yes hi um i was just wondering
because i think your work is really
special because you interact with both
like the
legal and like policy making side of um
people and also on the academia people
what would be some like
what is like some key difference or did
you find any key difference in
communicating your work and uh with like
um people who are on the policy maker
side
rather than people in academia and yeah
yeah i mean i think both in this case
and also just working across disciplines
in general
um it's always about finding how you can
translate what you know into terms that
the other person
or other sets of people understand so
just it's the same with policy makers
it's like you have to learn the terms
that they use
and then try to make sure that you're
you're getting on the same page
um oftentimes you know this means you
can't necessarily dive deep into
something that you find really exciting
about like some technical detail but
it's more about like giving you know the
higher level takeaway and sometimes you
know the kinds of questions that a
policymaker might ask sort of shows you
that they may not understand what's
technically possible so it's up to us as
computer scientists to say okay here's
what's technically possible
so that they can then understand how to
write the regulation to support things
that are actually possible so for
example i know in the eu
we were speaking to some folks here in
the law school who are saying that uh
they are trying to do put in legislation
where humans have or people on social
media have um
like access to a human decision maker
right when they are say kicked off a
platform or something like that
and so again one of the things we don't
know is like how easy is it to do that
like how easy is it to have an automated
system that detects when someone should
be kicked off and then how easy is it to
have someone you know appeal and then
have a decision maker actually come in
and and do something about it and so if
you don't have like a strong connection
between the technology and the policy
makers then the regulations are not
going to be written in a way that can
actually be implemented and executed and
so that's why i think it's really
important to have these dialogues but
again it's really about trying to figure
this out over time
um and figuring out how to speak the
language of the other side so to speak
or to get a shared language i should say
i see thank you for answer that yeah
that's that makes a lot of sense
hey
i have a question
um
so uh
the work on dark patterns was very
interesting one low-level question i had
about that is
how did you detect all of the dark
patterns was was that done by code or
did you have people look at all the
all the sites or how did that work yeah
um that's a very good question so um
basically you know once we've scripted
all the data we used um hierarchical
clustering
to cluster all the kind of textual parts
of all the screenshots into different
buckets and then we um had like expert
reviewers you know in this case the
student led the work and
some other collaborators basically go
through the data and qualitatively
like code it
and then you know from that actually
start to figure out like what were the
common things but we had before that
looked at all the different taxonomies
and all of the kind of anecdotal
evidence so in some cases we had some
ideas of what things might be
problematic
and it was easier to identify those but
in other cases you know we had to kind
of see what we were
seeing that was common and then kind of
try to put a name to it
and maybe a higher level question about
that uh
you know so these dark patterns can be
used for
purposes that are that are not so great
um
but
you can also imagine
people trying to use these patterns to
nudge
uh consumers and and people to doing
things that are
good for them
and yes i wonder if uh
if you could just speak to that and uh
you know how should we think about
differentiating between good uses of
these patterns and and negative uses
right
so um i that's an excellent question and
i'll point you to a research paper by
arnesh martha who
is the the former student who led this
work who's now actually going to be
working at a regular matrix body in the
uk for a while and he wrote a paper
that's you know basically what makes a
dark pattern dark because
i guess like the fundamental question
that's not easy to answer is when is a
manipulation problematic and when is it
actually doing something that maybe not
that harmful or or you know how do we
define harm even like is that financial
loss for someone is that mental health
issues um is that you know maybe someone
just got something extra in their cart
but they didn't actually purchase it um
and i think it's not that easy to draw
that line and as you pointed out
um you know nudging people has also been
used to kind of get people to opt into
insurance plans and things like that by
having pre-checked boxes right instead
of opting into something you have to opt
out
and so i feel like there's a lot of
research going on into how
different types of interfaces can be
problematic but perhaps one area of
research that we have less to say about
is um you know how are like these kinds
of manipulations actually not
problematic so how are some patterns
good and nudging people in a good
direction and so i think there's less in
that space
great thank you
all right well
thank you very much for that wonderful
talk martini
and um
i think we should finish for the day
okay
thank you so much i i you know like i
can't see who's in the room but um you
know very excited to be in and i thank
you for
the opportunity and i hope you all have
a nice day over there in california